françois bayrou le président du modem
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec la
fp alors on nous a pas encore entendu
évoqué le phénomène macron après le
lancement de son mouvement déjà
vingt-cinq mille adhérents au dernier
pointage et ce sera la première question
de l'émission françois bayrou est ce
qu'il peut réussir lui à dépasser le
clivage droite-gauche deuxième question
vous dirait des bois claude de l' agence
france-presse
si le gouvernement à apporter la bonne
réponse à la jeunesse enfin troisième
question avec michaël szames s l'europe
s'étiole peut-elle disparaître au grand
désespoir d'un fédéralistes comme vous
mais avant d'aborder chacune de ces
questions votre réaction aux révélations
du monde sur la surveillance du député
thierry solère par la dgse alors qu'il
était encore candidat face à à claude
guéant alors ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls juge cette surveillance
insupportable et vous alors si c'est
vrai si c'est prouvé
parce que évidemment c'est pas des
allégations
enfin on her ne s'appuie pas uniquement
sur des allégations mais si c'est prouvé
sa porte un nom extrêmement précis ça
s'appelle une forfaiture c'est à dire la
trahison par un officier public
quelqu'un qui occupe une fonction
publique de sa fonction les services
secrets les services de sécurité ils
sont pas là pour surveiller l'adversaire
politique du ministre qui est en place
peut-être ça s'est fait dans le passé
mais en tout cas c'est c'est une
atteinte intolérable à l'idée qu'on se
fait d'une fonction et à ce stade les
dénégations de clogher ne vous suffisent
pas puisqu'il assure n'avoir joué aucun
rôle dans cette affaire
il demande d'ailleurs aux ministres de
la défense de diligenter une enquête
si la phrase que vous me citez est exact
il ne dit pas que ça n'a pas eu lieu
il parle de son rôle à lui sont absents
violent l'espèce et il est franchement
comment imaginer
e&d démener de cet ordre soit conduite
contre l'adversaire électorale du
ministre sans que le ministre d'une
manière ou d'une autre n'est tenu à le
souhaiter
même si c'est souvent des basses
manoeuvres qu'on fait faire plutôt que
on ne les fais moi en tout cas je trouve
que si c'est vrai c'est encore une fois
des histoires d'officine dans la
république d'utilisation de des services
de l'état pour assurer la sécurité à des
fins bassement politiques
si c'est vrai c'est intolérable et c'est
une forfaiture intolérable dites-vous
comme le premier ministre est une
forfaiture ça vous fait je tairai pas
envie de vous dire que ça vous fait
jeter un nouveau regard sur le le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy est ce
que je me trompe
j'ai écrit un livre sur ce qui s'est
passé à cette époque qui s'appelait abus
de pouvoir parce que il me semblait
c'était un titre à plusieurs sens mais
il me semblait qu'il y avait dans la
pratique du pouvoir
je pensais par exemple à des affaires à
la ferme tapie qui depuis a été jugé par
la justice dans le sens que j'avais
analysé à cette époque je pensais qu'il
y avait là des choses keane qui n'allait
pas et si cette dernière affaire est
prouvée alors on est encore une fois
dans ce domaine de l'abus de pouvoir
affaire à suivre donc l'actualité
politique toujours animé par emmanuel
macron qui assure aujourd'hui être
ministre nuitées jours ce qui lui laisse
quand même le temps apparemment de
lancer son mouvement en marche en les
côtes défendre son engagement il ya des
femmes et des hommes de gauche je suis
aujourd'hui dans un gouvernement de
gauche je suis de gauche je viens de la
gauche mais j'ai envie de travailler
avec des femmes et des hommes de droite
et dont je ne me satisfais pas de la
géographie actuelle nous pouvons dans
une action commune une volonté commune
rassemblée des bonnes volontés de droite
et de gauche
celles et ceux qui croient dans le
travail l'émancipation par le travail
est véritablement améliorer la vie
des travailleurs des entrepreneurs des
investisseurs alors peut-il selon vont
réussir à dépasser le clivage le jose
entend rire alors la revente en parle
non je ne dépasser les clivages je
souris avec vous parce que j'avais
l'impression d'avoir entendu ces phrases
et souvent c'est vrai monstre agit non
partisane j'ai noté une volonté de
rassembler les bonnes volontés de brad
et de relancer votre vocabulaire votre
flambeau peut-être dans le dans le
vocabulaire c'est le même alors il ya
dans cette affaire deux choses la
première c'est que on peut au moins voir
que ça bouge que cette bipolarisation
que j'ai depuis si longtemps
diagnostiquée comme étant en fin de
course comme étant mourante et
commettant paralysante
cette bipolarisation elle s'effondre
sous nos yeux est que ce soit un
ministre du gouvernement de gauche avec
toutes les les toutes les protestations
de gauche que font les responsables
successifs qui disent que ça n'a plus de
sens alors d'une certaine manière ça
accrédite est la vôtre social temps des
dieux j'ai pas tout à fait fini ça
accrédite le sacré dit le diagnostic que
j'ai porté depuis longtemps puis il ya
une deuxième chose c'est qu'elle est le
fond de tout ça veut dire où ça mène
alors je suis un homme du centre je n'ai
jamais pensé que la droite et la gauche
n'existait pas j'ai dit que ce clivage
ne pouvait plus être le clivage dans
lequel on se reconnaissent mais moi ce
que je crois c'est qu'il y a un projet
original du centre que ça ressemble pas
et que ça n'est pas la même chose
est ce que je puis vous rappeler une
phrase que j'avais dit il ya longtemps
lorsqu'on a créé l'ump soi disant parti
unique de la droite et du centre
à l'époque les gens disaient mais on
pense tout la même chose
et j'avais dît si on pense tous la même
chose c'est qu'on ne pense plus rien et
l'idée que indifféremment tout le monde
se retrouve
sans connaître le projet parce que ce
qu'on entend ça n'a pas de sens je veux
dire ça n'a pas de profondeur moi ce qui
me manque c'est le projet dans tout ça
le projet de société
sans aller jusque là par exemple une
dizaine de réforme par exemple ferait
consensus web et ceci est autre chose ça
c'est une méthode c'est pas du tout sur
les comptes préconise la et donc le
l'absence de fonds l'absence de projet
construit est pour moi une interrogation
non un handicap ou le handicap est une
interrogation
le ce dont j'ai besoin c'est de savoir
où l'on va et par exemple le sentiment
que il n'y aurait que l'économie et que
l'économie financière qu'il faudrait
servir qu'au fond tout le monde serait
obligée d'en passer par là
ce cette petite musique qu'on entend il
suffit de voir les soutiens on parle
toujours de monsieur mac on en est à la
rue j'entends le procès à la fois de la
danse c'est pas un procès c'est une
interrogation pour moi ça ne correspond
pas à ce que j'attends d'en savoir ce
qu'attendent des millions de français
d'accord dans qu'est né à ce que et donc
le je pense que ce qui est très
important c'est de construire une vision
de l'avenir qu'ils apportent aux
français un peu de raisons de s'engager
quelque chose à quoi on croirait qu'ils
sont inscrits ne serait pas mais
financière et qui ne serait pas
uniquement le facteur commun comparer
d'écrire aujourd'hui d'accord avec avec
une on va dire une une
une présentation sommaire de
l'ultralibéral libéralisation du pays
donc vous ne verrez pas fait contre moi
j'ai rien compris j'ai bien écouté non
j'ai bien regardé ces derniers temps les
les lois proposées en particulier par
monsieur macron
bon je peux pas dire que j'ai que que je
ressente qu'il y est eu ces derniers
mois des changements profonds sur la
manière dont le pays est organisée alors
vous voyez là en travers
oui enfin bon quand on est entravée et
koné ministre on s'en va et c'est ce
qu'elle devrait faire une zone non pas
du tout je n'ai jamais dis ça je dis que
c'est une chose de dire on va travailler
tous ensemble c'est une autre chose de
dire vers quoi et à quoi va regarder
cette photo ce photomontage en fait
publiée par libération vous l'avez vu un
c'est emmanuel bayrou quand même vous
sentez un petit peu en affinité dont je
ne vous reconnais pas vraiment pas
vraiment mais vous voyez qu'on peut
utiliser les mêmes mots pour dire des
choses différent un peu différent donc
voilà donc vous ne reconnaissez pas dans
ce jeu vous m'a dit m'a un peu
différente j'ai dit différents
différents le g tout le but de mon
action politique et de mon engagement a
été depuis 15 ans d'une part de
diagnostiquer ce qui n'allait pas dans
la situation du pays souvenez-vous
vraiment le chemin vers la dette d'accor
les les affaires qu'ils étaient en train
de se développer notamment la
bipolarisation l'avenir à plein enfin le
blocage d un jeune qui arrive sur la
tant qu'on ne touche pas aux
institutions on est condamné à retourner
dans votre cave vers la droite non
lèvres dernière celeron excuses excusez
moi non je ne retourne pas j'ai fait le
constat
navré que la politique suivie par
françois hollande et par le gouvernement
était catastrophique que ont qu'une des
leçons avaient été tirées des essais que
nous étions en train de vivre et j'ai
donc exprimer mon opposition forte à ce
gouvernement alors on a entendu là alors
c'est pas un retour vers d'accord la
droite nommé corrigeons les cheveux le
le il se trouve que je ne crois pas à
votre
classification d'accord de qu'on ne
pourrait être que à gauche ou que à
droite je crois pas ça je crois qu'il ya
en france un plus râler croix du tout ce
que dit emmanuel ma contre c'est pas ça
non est ce que vous aimeriez travailler
avec lui
à écouter jeu pour tout vous dire je ne
le connais pas et je ne sais pas si
emmanuel macron abap ans
d'abord c'est parce qu'ils pensent
exactement et je ne sais pas s'ils
pensent les mêmes choses que ce que je
pense et que ce que pensent tous ceux
qui depuis des années ont voulu bâtir
une alternative à cette bipolarisation
stupide au passage à leurs méthodes
je me réjouis que ça bouge mais dans le
fond et notamment dans le dans le projet
pour construire un nouveau monde
j'ai beaucoup de points d'interrogation
et donc quand à moi je
j'affirme qu'il faut construire une
alternative à ce que nous avons vécu
depuis dix ans voilà c'est clair sur vos
positions au passage françois bayrou
jacques de leur estime nécessaire une
alliance entre les socialistes et les
centristes pour des réformes dans notre
pays et ils vous reprochent dans un
livre d'entretiens qui s'appelle l'homme
qui ne voulait pas être roi d'avoir
refusé de le soutenir au premier tour
quand il avait finalement renoncé à se
présenter à la présidentielle soit vous
sauver de son lancement fin 94 alors que
vous vous étiez vu à l'époque oui mais
j'ai il se trouve que jacques delors est
un des hommes politiques dont j'ai été
le plus proche intellectuellement et
peut-être même affectivement au cours de
ma vie politique et je crois qu'il ne
vous dirai pas le contraire est ce que
jacques delors dit dans ce livre qui est
absolument vrai c'est que je ne pouvais
pas le soutenir au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle je vous
rappelle que j'étais membre du
gouvernement balladur et qu' edouard
balladur se présentait au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle et que mon
parti avaient massivement décidé de le
soutenir mais j'avais dit à jacques
delors je suis prêt à vous soutenir au
deuxième ah d'accord alors écouter ce
que dit à peu près enfin en disant il
m'avait dit qu'il me soutiendrait au
premier tour il a dit ça ouais écouter
ce que dit au sujet de emmanuel macron
et sur sa compatibilité avec alain juppé
jean pierre raffarin
je ne vois aucune incompatibilité entre
emmanuel macron et alain juppé donc que
là il y as peut-être pour l'avenir des
signaux intéressants
c'est à dire par exemple vous imagine
emmanuel macron premier ministre alain
juppé président il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité entre les deux
sensibilités et de tempérament les deux
cultures je trouvais donc qu'il y ait
dans l'avenir des partenariats je ne
sais sous quelle forme ça ne me paraît
pas impossible en 2017 il va falloir
réformer profondément fermement la
france il va falloir le faire vite on
aura besoin de tous les talents
il peut renaître alors vous imaginez ça
il m'a donné ma compromis ministre naji
non mais ça c'est le sait ce que vous
avez conclu de ce que disait raffarin je
suis pas absolument réparer le mont
perdu leur sourire
c'est une non pas compatibles mais je
voyez-vous ce que j'espère d'alain juppé
ça n'est pas qu'ils se contentent de
rechercher le plus petit commun
dénominateur entre la majorité actuelle
l'opposition actuelle et les politiques
prônées par les uns ou par les autres
ce que j'espère d'alain juppé sait qu'il
va avoir la force et le courage de
proposer une politique qui soit
profondément différente de ce que nous
avons connu depuis des années ça que
j'attends d'accord mais alors il n'y
qu'un programme pépère jusqu'à présent
ce qu'il propose alain juppé oui je
n'utilise pas ce genre d'adjectifs mais
l'idée est un peu non le
le radical ce qui m'intéresse chez alain
juppé c'est que précisément il n'est pas
dans le moule habituelles y compris de
son parti et qu'il dit il va falloir une
majorité qui soit une majorité
différente des majorités que nous avons
connu dans les années précédentes dans
les cycles précédents est cette phrase
si vous y réfléchissez en profondeur
vous y reconnaîtrez un grand nombre d
aspiration que j'ai défendue devant les
français tako à ce que sur le fond du
programme que d'y nouer quelques mois qu
est ce que vous vous demandez alain
juppé non je voudrais vous attendez ce
j'attends que nous nous trouvions à
partir de 2017 dans un nouveau cycle
dans une nouvelle ère de la vie
politique française dans laquelle on
réponde de manière différente à toutes
les aspirations des français sur
l'éducation où on a échoué et gravement
a mon avis part par manque de réflexion
sur le fond par exemple
j'attends qu'on rompe clairement avec la
politique actuelle du gouvernement en
matière éducative menée à 20 contre la
réforme de l'école âgé en particulier
j'attends une rupture franche
j'attends que on se trouve avec une
politique qui permette de qu'une
confiance nouvelle phase créer des
contrats de travail alors que c'est à
peu près le contraire de ce qu'on est en
train de faire entend parler dans une
minute
j'attends que la france est une
proposition européenne différent de ce
que nous avions jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
va en parler tout à l'heure dans le
troisième secteur ce sont des demandes
que vous vous adressez donc et ce sont
des demandes que l'âme que j'adresse la
priorité à tous ceux qui aiment avoir la
responsabilité
j'espère de porter l'alternance dans le
pays et pour moi c'est le fond de mon
engagement on n'est pas là uniquement
pour des problèmes de personnes ont
alors que les personnes ça compte
beaucoup mon élection présidentielle
mais on est là pour changer la réalité
du pays alors c'est ce que veut le faire
beaucoup de français qui sont lassés des
jeux politiques justement vous le voyez
avec les nuits de boue à paris dans
d'autres villes de province avec
également la primaire citoyenne que
certains veulent
certains de vos proches d'ailleurs comme
jean marie cavada qu'avait kavanagh qui
s'intègre dans cette nouvelle démarche
est ce que vous êtes vous même indigné
en soi bayrou sait pas ce que ça veut
dire
ce sont d un leit motiv qui revient ce
sont des étiquettes que l'on colle après
un mouvement qui s'est déroulé en
espagne et lequel mouvement déroulée en
espagne a touché sa limite en n'ayant
aucun débouché politique
en plus on a découvert ces jours ci que
le financement de ces mouvements étaient
tout sauf transparent qui amène
venezuela notamment aux les rangs et
l'iran sont pas des pays démocratiques
bah c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire non
trouvez pas et donc oui je trouve que
kiala quelque chose qui est une limite
il faut se méfier la nuit de boot ces
mouvements là je crois que j'ai été un
des premiers à dire qu' il fallait y
attacher de l'importance que ce n'était
pas quelque chose a écarté d'un revers
de main cependant la question c'est vers
quoi cela mène-t-il ou est ce que ça
nous entraîne quel est l'horizon qu'on
se propose parce que ce que je lis dans
les déclarations des uns et des autres
et elles sont compliquées dans dans ce
mouvement
c'est que en fait ils ne demandent pas
de changement ils veulent pas de chants
ils veulent que le système s'écroule ils
veulent un changement de société en
langue nouvelle nouvelle que le système
s'écroule
et moi je ne veux pas que notre société
je veux qu'elles trouvent une nouvelle
vie un nouvel élan qu'on puisse croire à
quelque chose et qu'on soit pas les uns
et les autres
abandonné à cette désespérance qui nous
en veille alors évidemment qui envahit
les gens pouvaient jamais désiré cesser
ces mouvements en tous les cas se
nourrissent de la désespérance de la
déception née de l'alternance de 2012
françois bayrou est ce que vous croyez à
la possibilité pour françois hollande de
se relancer il sera face au français
demain soir sur france 2 moi je n'y
crois pas ne croyez pas non
je pense que françois hollande a
bénéficié d'un crédit qui était aussi
largement du refus de nicolas sarkozy de
la poursuite de son mandat il a
bénéficié d'un crédit
il a gaspillé ce crédit en refusant
d'aller au bout des changements et des
réformes et des pratiques c'est il en
avait la responsabilité
maintenant c'est trop tard et je ne
crois pas qu'il puisse retrouver son cri
à propos de cette émission il ya une
polémique sur un conducteur qui aurait
été visé par l'elysée est et d'où aurait
été supprimé 2 français du panel
sélectionné ça vous inspire une
réflexion vous voulez dire que il peut
arriver que des chaînes de télévision
négocié avec l'elysée quand elle invite
le président de la république vous
m'étonnez beaucoup là franchement parce
que vous savez bien que jamais ça ne se
produit ce genre de choses vous êtes
vous êtes géorgie accordé genre gisèle
qu'un qui avait une grande expérience et
vous savez que jamais au grand jamais il
est le genre d'accommodement ne se
produit jean religieux l'ironie de votre
nom votre allée deuxième partie de
preuves par 3 avec deborah claude de la
fp qui nourrit avoir j'imagine dans -
président quelque chose comme ça prend
deux résidents je n'interviendrai pas
dhr alors et cette question le
gouvernement at il apporté la bonne
réponse à la jeunesse avec son plan pour
faire donc retomber la pression et la
contestation de la de travail
satisfaction d'un côté de l'unef
toujours hostile au texte mejia belle
connerie et colère de la cgpme qui
estime avoir reçu un coup de poignard
dans le dos notamment avec la taxation
des cdd tout ça vous en doutez ne lève
pas tous les désaccords et je pense
notamment celui sur le projet de loi
travail qui n'est toujours pas une bonne
loi pour les jeunes donc c'est
évidemment pour ça et que l'unef elles
restent solidaires des salariés et de
leur mobilisation le 28 avril que nous
restons solidaires de l'intersyndicale
des mots d'ordre mais je crois que dès
aujourd'hui nous avons franchi un cap
important nous avons réussi à obtenir
satisfaction sur des revendications nous
apprenons nous chefs d'entreprise
et bien qu'on allait rendre obligatoire
la taxation des cdd il suffit qu'une
organisation d'étudiantes et d'étudiants
qui représente 14 mille étudiants et
bien arrive à obtenir une taxation des
cdd qui va impacter 3 millions
d'entrepreneurs voilà croire qu'en
taxant le travail on va favoriser le
passage de cdd en cdi
c'est complètement illusoire bonsoir
deborah claude en question bayrou alors
on va parler du roi elle connerie est ce
qu'elle est maintenant devenue la loi
une oeuvre en tout cas il ya une chose
qu'on doit constater et qui je trouve
crève les yeux c'est que une nouvelle
fois le gouvernement est parti avec des
intentions et on se retrouve avec une
loi qui est exactement opposée aux
intentions qui avait été annoncé sur
beaucoup de sujets mais sur ce sujet là
en particulier et je trouve ça terrible
pour pour le pour le jugement que le
gouvernement doit porter sur lui-même
pourquoi ben c'est très simple le
gouvernement avait dit nous allons
alléger le travail et le rendre plus
souples étant donné que tout le monde à
peu près quelles que soient les
responsabilités et en particulier les
universitaires qui travaillent sur le
travail parce que faut quand même
prendre ce travail là c'est
universitaire 10
il ya deux choses qui pénalise le
travail en france c'est le coût du
travail
d'un côté et c'est de l'autre côté la
rigidité des contrats de travail c'est
pour ça que 80
un bis % ou presque 5 % des contrats
signés sont des contrats en cdd et donc
grosso modo tout le monde avait dit les
prix nobel d'économie jean tirole les
responsables politiques j'en suis avait
dit la bonne direction s'est en effet
allégé assouplir que fait-on on alourdit
on se retrouve au bout du chemin on
alourdit et en régie d'ifi 20 minutes
bien que son projet reste équilibré mais
aujourd'hui oui mais ça plaide pour
l'emploi durable mélodies madame elle
connaît les ministres seront là c'est
leur métier quelquefois de dire y
compris le contraire de ce qu'il pense
ou qu'on les oblige à dire y compris le
contraire de ce qu'il pense moi en tout
cas je ne change pas d'opinion
ce ce changement de cap est pour le
gouvernement a à un symptôme
d'impuissance et de faiblesse et
d'impuissance et de faiblesse en
particulier parce que le gouvernement
vous dites est ce qu'il a répondu à la
jeunesse c'est une blague sur les
bourses c'est cette occasion non mais
parlons de ce sujet finissons avec ce
sujet c'est une blague
ce qu'on appelle à l'organisation et à
la jeunesse c'est une organisation qui
comporte quelques quelques milliers de
militants et qui tend à se faire passer
pour le porte parole des autres les
jeunes français cl si si on veut bien
partager avec eux un dialogue en
profondeur qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce
qui doit crever les yeux mais à ce qui
crève les yeux c'est qu'ils sont au
chômage et que on trouve infiniment
moins de travail chez nous même quand on
est diplômé qu'on en trouve ailleurs on
en trouve davantage diplômés que pas
diplômés mais les les taux de chômage
sont effrayants et la manière dont on
conduit cette chose va les accentuer
parce que si vous croyez que c'est en
alourdissant le céder dès qu'on favorise
le cdi vous vous mettez le doigt dans
l'oeil jusqu'à l'omoplate
alors vous avez désespérant comme penser
et c'est désespérant comme faiblesse
c'est désespérant comme incapacité à
définir un cap et à défendre ce cas
alors un nouveau manuel valls et ils
n'essaient d'anaïs en tous les cas de
jean-françois copé qui évoque écouter le
premier ministre qui promettait d'aller
jusqu'au bout je ne reconnais pas manuel
valls en fait moi on ma toujours
expliqué que le premier ministre et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je lui
trouvais un certain un certain
tempérament c'était quelqu'un qui tenait
dans les moments difficiles
manuel valls il n'est plus le droit dans
ses bottes il est un concept beaucoup de
choses aux jeunes bon c'est quelqu'un
que j'estime donc je vais pas le joindre
au groupe de ceux qui l'accablent même
si mon jugement sur cette décision est
extrêmement sévère mais je pense qu'il
doit pas être fier de lui il doit pas
être content c'est pas 2 c'est pas la
direction qu'ils avaient tracé
ce n'est pas le courage qu'il avait
défini et c'est encore une fois un faux
semblant
quand on pense qu'on prétend défendre
les jeunes en en imposant l'immobilisme
dans une situation qui les conduit au
chômage
je trouve ça désespérant alors autre
élément dans les annonces qui ont été
faites hier tout cela un coup vous avez
souvent plaidé pour le désendettement de
la france 4 à 500 millions d'euros est
ce qu'on peut se les offrir
vous voyez dans quelle période nous
sommes entrés c'est dans la période du
carnet de chèques
ouvert à tous les vents de chèque en
blanc à profusion chèque à profusion jeu
si on fait la liste des annonces qui ont
été faites ces derniers jours ces
dernières heures
vous avez 4 à 500 millions ici 800
millions là bas 600 millions ailleurs
c'est dit toujours mais attendez on va
faire des économies et videmment ce sont
des chèques en blanc alors je ne dis pas
que telle ou telle mesure par exemple le
point des fonctionnaires le point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires étaient
bloqués de la ville six ans et je pense
que bon peut pas s'y opposer mais on
devrait d'ailleurs moi compris dans le
collectif bien sûr ça coûte très cher à
une collectivité locale dans la
collectivité que je dirige à pau et dans
l'agglomération de pau ça coûte un
million deux cent mille euros
et vous trouvez-vous l'argent et donc
alors est le même des économies alors au
niveau de la municipalité nous ne
faisons des économies depuis que je suis
élu pour pouvoir
on fait des économies de fonctionnement
pour pouvoir continuer à investir car le
lien est extrêmement direct et précis
si vous ne faites pas d'économie vous ne
pouvez pas emprunter pour investir et
c'est le grand drame de l'investissement
en france dont souffrent vous le savez
et nous parce que nous faisons le plus
possible d'économies de fonctionnement
nous pouvons continuer à investir mais
vous voyez bien que tout ça est
terriblement pénalisant est en tout cas
je je je n'ai jamais approuvé la
politique du carnet de chèques
ouvert à tous les mêmes quand les taux
d'intérêt sont proches de zéro et que
l'on perd mais en ça nous permet
d'emprunter comme ça très bon qu'on
enverra le poids de la dette s'allège
même françois bayrou
excusez moi qu'on emprunte pour investir
j'ai toujours été pour qu'on emprunte
pour les frais courants de l'état
j'ai toujours été contre et ici ce qu'on
appelle déficit de l'état qui se
transforme en bête puisque pour et
équilibrée le déficit il faut emprunter
c'est du déficit de fonctionnement
l'état investit quasiment rien et donc
que c'est de très mauvaises méthodes
il ya eu quelques petites améliorations
sur le déficit ces derniers temps ça
vous saluer
attendez faut il faut préciser ce qu'on
dit françois hollande s'était engagé
croix de bois croix de fer si je mens je
vais en enfer
il s'était engagé sur le fait qu'en 2017
on serait un déficit zéro et que dès
2000 dans les clous des cultes et 2013
on serait passé à moins de 3% vous
souvenez de ces engagements là et bien
on est toujours à plus de 3% le déficit
zéro s'est éloigné comme comme les rêves
au matin et tout ceci est aux antipodes
de vin ou présente maintenant comme des
victoires affirma démentiel thomas
seraient passés sous les barres de la
barre des 3% annoncée en 2013 ce qui
devait être fait réaliser un tournoi
tard alors dans l'actualité n'aime pas
quelque chose qu'on a c'est qu'on n'a
pas fait le chemin se faut dire les
choses comme elles sont dans leur ai dit
que c'était facile à elle je dis que moi
pas fait dans l'actualité tout autre
chose la relance de la question de la
dépénalisation de l'usagé du cannabis
avec deux ministres pour deux points de
vue d'ailleurs on regarde
et puis vous me donnerez votre opinion
sur cette question pensent que la
prohibition du cannabis en france est en
tout cas une mesure qui mérite d'être
discuté je pense qu'il faut aller
peut-être vers des mécanismes de
légalisation contrôlée mais surtout avec
des politiques d'éducation et de santé
publique et de lutte très forte contre
la consommation de cannabis non ce n'est
pas la position du gouvernement
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il l'a lui-même
dit c'est une position qu'il défend
depuis longtemps parce que j'ai souvent
entendu parler ces questions en tant que
médecin il a une position qui est assez
claire d'autres l'ont eu aussi sur ce
sujet mais ce n'est pas la position du
gouvernement
c'est un débat qui revient régulièrement
sur la place publique et qui fracturent
une partie de la gauche vous quelle est
votre opinion sur le sujet bon je vais
essayer de le dire en trois phrases
première phrase nos politiques de lutte
contre la toxicomanie ne marche pas et
notamment contre le cannabis présenté à
tort ou à raison je crois plutôt à tort
comme une drogue douce
le mais l'alcool aussi est une drogue et
qui n'est pas douce il suffit de voir
les addictions qui sont créées
deuxièmement je ne crois pas que la
consommation de cannabis soit anodine je
dis pas pour ceux qui fument comme ça
une cigarette
enfin point le 5 juin il y en a qui ont
eu une consommation festive modéré mais
malheureusement je connais des
adolescents qui ont une consommation qui
n'est pas festive et qui est tragique
il ya aussi comme vous savez des
consommations d'alcool chez les
adolescents qui sont pas qu'ils sont
tragiques aussi une deuxième chose crois
pas que ce soit anodin je pense que ça a
un effet psychotrope de psychotropes
dangereux troisièmement on nous dit ça
va si on le légalisons va faire baisser
leur invite les trafics et les violences
et on va avoir des cités assainies je
n'en crois rien parce que les le les
ressources tirées de ces trafics
elles seront recherchés ailleurs et dans
des drogues par exemple le crack on sait
bien c'est aux états unis que violent
des drogues plus violent 800 et donc et
donc c'est un débat très difficile mais
je ne vais pas en tout cas qu'on puisse
le résumé sous la forme qui en est faite
par les promoteurs de cette mesure et
moi je ne suis pas favorable à la
légalisation du cannabis même langue on
faisait pour le statu quo non je je je
pense que le travail de prévention n'est
pas fait et je suis pas pour le statu
quo de ce point de vue là je pense que
le travail de le travail d'étude et de
prévention dépasser mais dans la
réglementation actuelle la répression
vous voulez
rien changé là on peut toujours faire
plus vraiment matière de prévention mais
quand vous dites par exemple la
consommation festive on a envie de vous
interroger qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que ça veut dire précisément je veux
dire la mesure et comment là je ne vais
pas dire voilà c'est quand je dis c'est
une consommation dangereuse je sais très
bien qu'il ya beaucoup d'adolescents qui
filme détenteurs qui à qui il arrive de
fumer un joint jeudi pas pour autant
qu'ils sont détruits dans leur équilibre
psychologique mais je dis que la
consommation de cannabis addictives et
fortes et dangereuses du point de vue de
la santé publique
du point de vue de l' équilibre de ces
adolescents il y à des sensibilités
particulières qui conduisent à de grave
grave dérive désordre et pathologie et
donc j'ai pas envie de présenter ça
comme anodin et évidemment si on le
légalisait le signe serait à l'égard des
jeunes que c'est anodin on paye pour le
soin le cannabis pour le soin parce que
ça peut être utilisé comme moyen
thérapeutique ça franchement sonne ça ne
me dérangerait pas d'accord mais quand
jean marie le guen mais ce sujet sur la
table aujourd'hui vous pensez que c'est
une diversion par rapport à tous les
sujets qu'on abordait jouit présence sur
les ja oui je pense que c'est une
diversion et je pense que c'est oui une
une manière de de retrouver croates on
sait d'ailleurs discuté
moralement et de retrouver quoi ton 2
voilà de l'audience auprès des
entreprises mais jeunes entre guillemets
comme si c'était une catégorie sociale
ce à quoi je ne crois pas alors encore
dans l'actualité deborah nous avons noté
la décision d'épiscopat aujourd'hui de
faire toute la lumière sur les affaires
de pédophilie y compris les plus
anciennes écouté monseigneur georges
pontier tout à l'heure le président de
la conférence des évêques annonce
notamment une commission indépendante
c'est ce que nous voulons travailler
avec cette commission extérieure
d'experts qui nous permettra d'évaluer a
entre guillemets dangerosité d'un
individu fut-il prêtre par rapport à un
ministère qui pourrait correspondre aux
yeux de la loi
un mystère qu'on peut lui donner
l'église est dans la tourmente depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est cette volonté
de faire un peu plus la lumière sur ces
affaires et de créer des commissions ça
vous semble une bonne idée
la pédophilie est une atteinte à la
dignité et à la vie des enfants
c'est une s'éteint c'est un des actes
les plus graves qu'on puisse commettre à
l'égard d'un enfant et qui le laisse à
vie atteint il ya des gravité différente
dans cette atteinte aucune indulgence
aucune connivence n'est acceptable
est ce que l'église est plus touchée que
d'autres
la ministre de l'éducation a annoncé la
suspension de 29 enseignants il y a dans
tous ceux qui sont au contact des
enfants dans les
c'est bien dans les collectes assez
classique locale il ya des cas de cet
ordre qui entraîne des radiations et
donc oui il faut être intransigeant et
tout le travail qu'on pourra faire je
passais une commission peut apporter
quelque chose
mais tout le travail qu'on pourra faire
ses duels d'ego dégageant aura mon
soutien des cellules d'écouté seront
ouvertes partout en france et les
personnes aujourd'hui adultes parfois
effectivement et quand vécu ce genre de
traumatisme pourront apporter leurs
témoignages c'est une bonne chose c'est
un changement qui est quand même
ensemble semble-t-il de l'église qui est
l'autre ce qui s'est passé dans le fatah
je ne crois pas que ce soit un problème
spécifiquement au coeur de l'église
je pense que c'est un problème de la
société je pense qu'on a été trop
indulgent au travers du temps en
considérant qu'après tout et moi je m'en
faire rêver un bel été gazés corps il va
réviser moi je me suis porté sur ce
sujet a aucune indulgence
je pense qu'on a profondément heurté et
blessé des enfants et moi en tout cas je
ne prête aucune aucune sorte de de
nuances dans la condamnation d'accord de
toutes les institutions on vous a
compris driss absolument merci merci les
verts à troisième partie de preuves par
3 aider nous allons parler de l'europe
avec michaël szames s l'europe à la
peine on le voit en ce moment exposé à
la critique la désaffection et même le
rejet sur bien des dossiers les réfugiés
bien sûr le break site manuel valls est
à strasbourg aujourd'hui pour tenter de
peser sur l'adoption du fameux pnr le
fichier des passagers aériens vus bien
sûr comme un outil important aujourd'hui
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme on
écoute le premier ministre si nous
voulons un pnr nationale pour qu'il
fonctionne pour qu'il soit efficace il
doit aller de pair avec un pnr européens
et nous devons donc nous doter de tous
les moyens dans cet équilibre
il faut toujours articulé entre sécurité
et liberté fondamentale bonsoir mitel vs
saint-michel vôtre monsieur bayrou soir
le pnr nous manuel valls par l'instance
est l'armé essentielle contre le
terrorisme ans est une des armes et il
faut prendre toutes les armes
disponibles tous adoptés c'est le mot
que je cherchais toutes les armes
disponibles et celle là en particulier
et je ne comprends pas alors je sais
très bien les débats qui a autour de
tout ça qui est des gens qui pensent que
la confiscation des données est utilisé
contre les libertés
moi je ne vois pas ce risque ce que je
vois c'est au contraire qu'on favorise
la plus grande atteinte à la liberté qui
est l'insécurité
ce texte est la menace y compris sur la
vie ce texte devrait être voté jeudi
c'est ce qu'on laisse supposer me vaut
tard que jamais comme ça j'aurais
préféré qu'il fut adopté depuis
longtemps ça prouve aussi quand même le
fonctionnement de cette union européenne
qui est souvent bloquée par des petits
partis notamment au vert au front
national et non je ne partage pas ce sur
ce point je ne partage pas ce sentiment
on va venir au fonctionnement de l'union
européenne je pense qu'il ya des
courants de pensée qui s'opposent à ces
textes sachant ce qu'ils font je veux
dire avec si je crois mais gagner ça
avec de bonnes raisons pour eux
philosophique doctrinale de défense des
libertés
mais le
pour moi leur est si grave et la menace
si lourdes qu'il faut ne rejeter ou de
repousser
aucune arme qui nous permettent de
lutter contre et pour le reste c'est
très simple s'il y a atteinte s'il doit
y avoir atteinte à la liberté à laquelle
nous avons droit
cela doit toujours se faire sous le
contrôle d'un juge c'est simple comme
bonjour
et c'est une règle qui ne souffre pour
moi pas d'exception alors vous avez dû
suivre avec attention j'imagine tout le
scandale autour des panamas papers sa
voisine que vous avez regarder ça de
très près le débat du jour à la
commission européenne
c'est d'imposer la transparence fiscale
pour les multinationales qui ont un
chiffre d'affaires plus de 500 à 750
millions d'euros
c'est à se demander même si le scandale
du pana papers ne vient pas un peu comme
une aubaine pour l'union européenne
non mais j'aurais envie de dire enfin
franchement que qui failli attendre la
sortie d'information de cet ordre pour
imposer la transparence à des sociétés
multinationales qui passent leur temps à
fuir l'impôt au vu et au su de tout le
monde y compris lorsque leurs ressources
sont prises sur la collectivité
nationale réfugiant leurs profits
recherchant refuge ou peu leurs profits
ailleurs et donc je souhaite que là
aussi l'union européenne soit
intransigeante pratiquement pas dans les
mots dans les faits alors les mots même
que je souhaite que c'est pas si vous
avez l'intention qu'on passe une minute
sur l'europe parce que c'est un travail
et entendre les mots justement de
johnathan de ville sur ce projet de
transparence fiscale
c'est le commissaire européen à la
stabilité financière et voilà comment il
présente donc les mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui qui ne relève pas
directement vers la conséquence de
panama peppers pour l'heure selon lui
parce que c'était programmé m'enfin il
ya effectivement ça tombe à pic comme
disait michael est donc cette
proposition qu'on nous dévoilant
aujourd'hui se fonde sur ce travail en
cours et ce sous l'égide
ocde le but étant d'obtenir une
information partagée est partagé entre
les autorités fiscales
cette proposition finalement va même un
peu plus loin puisque elle exigera aussi
de ces grandes multinationales formation
elle rendre ces informations clés ça
vous va ce qui est dit c'était de la
mena ça vous va alors je suis pour à
bruxelles on s'inquiète par contre une
chose c'est la tiédeur française sur ce
texte parce que visiblement on saurait
nous en tout cas plus enclins à faire de
la protection de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
on n'a pas vraiment envie d'y aller sur
ce texte et bien si c'est le cas je sais
pas si c'est vrai ce serait très
regrettable et condamnable l'europe 1
souffre de quoi elle souffre d'une
espèce d'impuissance elle souffre d'un
désordre intérieur parce que les règles
adoptées par les uns ne sont pas les
mêmes que les règles adoptées par les
autres notamment en matière fiscale
c'est à dire que pour moi le combat pour
l'harmonisation fiscale
l'unification de nos règles fiscales en
tout cas dans les pays de même niveau de
développement
c'est un enjeu de première priorité et
l'europe elle souffre d'une deuxième
chose que tout ça illustre si on y
réfléchit bien c'est que on ne sait pas
qui prend les décisions
quand on prend les décisions sur quel
agenda on prend les décisions
quels sont les quels sont les mécanismes
qui permettent de prendre les décisions
personne ne le sait y compris pas vous
mêmes de questions et même nous trois
rois c'est à dire que verser nous sommes
parmi les plus à verre est un trio
ambroisie un peu non c'est inquiétant
pour tous les citoyens
nous sommes en principe pas remis les
plus avertis qui savait qu'on était en
train de préparer ce texte parmi vous
qui est ce que c'est ça que je trouve
plus beaucoup plus informés que je ne le
suis parce que c'est ça que les français
rejettent dans l'union européenne
oui ce que pour moi la principale raison
du gouffre qui s'est creusé entre
l'union européenne et ses mécanismes
politiques et les citoyens de tous les
pays européens c'est le mur qui fait que
les citoyens ne sont informés de rien or
il est impossible aux siècles
démocratique que des décisions majeures
pour les sociétés les citoyens soient
prises sans que personne n'en soit
informé est ce que vous saviez pas et
donc c'est cette question la centrale
c'est à dire de la 2de l'ouverture de au
moins de l'information et de
l'information préalable pour que si une
décision se préparent les citoyens
puissent intervenir sont à préparer un
gouvernement des droits vous attendez
quoi finalement aujourd'hui à ben
j'attends que l'europe change du tout au
tout sa pratique car ce que je décris là
y'a pas besoin de changer les traités
y a pas besoin il suffit comme la
politique française visiblement oui
c'est à peu près ça mais pour l'union
européenne c'est plus dommageable encore
parce que les citoyens français et les
autres citoyens européens ils voient
bien le monde
il voit la mondialisation y voit la
concurrence effrénée international il
voit le poids de puissance financière
très importante
il voit le terrorisme et il voit le
crime organisé et il voit les migrations
voit tout ça elle réclame il aimait ou
ça vous parle evo9 le mur de
l'information nous est mûr irait tous au
fond d'eux mêmes ils sont bien content
qu'on peut pas lutter tout seul est ce
que vous savez qu'un pays comme la
france
même un gant pays européen peut pas
lutter tout seul alors à faire ce a
fortiori des pays qui pèse moins encore
que la france et l'allemagne
donc l'idée qu'il faille aller vers la
mutualisation de nos efforts la volonté
d'agir ensemble
c'est une idée qui s'imposent et
s'imposera à une condition c'est que ça
se fasse avec la avec la légitimité que
des décideurs doivent avoir auprès des
peuples
comprenez ce que je veux dire et ceci
c'est le l'urgence maximale tant qu'on
n'aura pas ça on aura le rejet et ce
rejet et le rejet du seul avenir que
nous puissions espérer donc j'avais une
question quand même sur le secret des
affaires et là ça va rejoindre un petit
peu ce que vous disiez on débat du
secret des affaires et un temps parle de
transparence la chine europe
schizophrène
oui je mais nous parlons de transparence
fiscale
moi je ne demande pas qu'on soit informé
de la manière dont les marchés se
négocie entre telle entreprise et l
autre entreprise
vous voyez c'est toujours pareil on
confond tourner utilise les mots que 1
ça fait un salmigondis un salmigondis un
boulbi boulga dans lequel personne ne
reconnaît ces deux reconnaît demandé le
sens et votre le sens des shows tels je
demande que quand on parle ça veut dire
quelque chose et je demande que on est
des règles compréhensible par tous les
citoyens
la règle c'est que la fiscalité doit
s'appliquer à tous les agents
économiques de la même façon dans les
pays européens du même niveau de
développement
est ce que vous êtes encore animé par un
rêve fédéralistes ou est ce qu'il sait
l'art évaporé hall non non les
insurrections électrique je peux pas
vous faire reproche de ne pas avoir lu
mes livres parce que j'en ai écrit mais
mais largement à l'association
répondront le mot fédéraliste est un mot
très difficile à comprends pas pourquoi
parce que la philosophie fédéraliste à
laquelle j'adhère
c'est une philosophie de confiance au
terrain de décentralisation maximales
tandis que la manière dont le mot
fédéraliste est entendu en france ça
veut dire exactement le contraire ça
veut dire concentration du pouvoir à
bruxelles
je ne suis pas pour la concentration du
pouvoir
je suis pour que soit créé un contrat de
confiance qui fasse simplement que les
pays européens choisissent ensemble de
régler en commun les affaires qu'ils ne
peuvent pas régler tout seul
comprenez ça alors ça porte un nom très
compliqué
appelle la subsidiarité si thomas
d'aquin le philosophe on s'est inventé
ça et donc de donc je le mot que
j'utilise c'est le mot coopératif c'est
la corde
c'est une démarche coopérative comme
temps des paysans peuvent pas rendre
leur maïs tout seul il se met encore
opéra libre de faire les choses un petit
musée des questions autour du nous nous
en europe les pays-bas refusé l'accord
entre l'union européenne et l'ukraine
c'est un mauvais signal je vous dire ce
que je pense je pense que quelques
référendums que vous feriez aujourd'hui
sur l'europe si vous n'avez pas changé
cette dimension fondamentale de la prise
de décision ouverte aux citoyens
obtiendra un nom éric demain pour la les
britanniques les peuples dans la
démarche dans laquelle ils sont engagés
ou dans laquelle on les a engagés on les
a engagés par ignorance de leurs
aspirations et de leurs droits car c'est
leur droit
les peuples répondront non donc pour les
britanniques savaient donc si selon vous
je ne sais pas s'il est si les pays bas
si le si le peuple néerlandais comme on
dit en mauvais français savait ce qu'il
ce sur quoi ils votaient non vraiment
pas du tout des bêtes à la complice et
sav voté et ils ont voté à 30 cas 30%
lille ont voté non et donc oui je suis
extrêmement inquiet inquiet en tout cas
il semble que les forces qui sont à
l'oeuvre devrait entraîner aussi où
peuvent entraîner aussi un nom à
l'angleterre
ce que je ne souhaite pas tout en
déplorant les concessions qui ont été
faites à la grande bretagne dans un
climat de d'absence de de solidité des
responsables européens pour être donnée
aux britanniques
en tout cas on a donné mal moi j'aurais
ouvert des discussions avec les
britanniques par une phrase simple 1
si vous voulez partir vous partez
parce que ce à quoi nous nous sommes
engagés est tellement important que si
vous voulez pas y participer vous partez
et c'est votre responsabilité 2
je suis prêt à négocier avec vous si
vous me dites que vous restez d'accord
ça c'est une
c'est une démarche complètement
différente et si vous me dites que vous
restez alors peut-être pouvons-nous en
profiter pour améliorer les modes de
fonctionnement non ce qu'il faut
redouter peut-être demain s'il y abrite
effectivement et c'est ce que dit le fmi
aujourd'hui c'est une déflagration
économique mais à l'échelle du continent
je peux vous enseigner si le peuple
britannique dit non il s'en mordra les
doigts et nous et nous nous aurons nous
aussi avoir des remises en cause mais
des mets des remises en cause qui peut
être pour quelques unes d'entre elles
pourrait être salutaire
merci françois bayrou d'avoir eric nos
sept semaines merci michael la semaine
prochaine c'est stéphane le foll le
porte parole du gouvernement et le
ministre de l'agriculture qui sera à
votre place bonsoir à tous et à très
vite